là tout est le seul rempart entre la
lumière et les ténèbres
[Applaudissements]
les milliers de générations de chevalier
fait serment de la protéger et je suis
le seul qui rêve
là tout va s'écrouler
habitué au carnage
aujourd'hui la guerre arrive sur terre
[Musique]
duport vraiment tu peux m'arrêter
maintenant
tout ce qui marche très bonne humeur se
finit
mesure pas avec la marque
kir avec maltais
je ne suis pas avec mon arme
je suis avec mon coeur
[Musique]
baylet bravo à ceux qui ont le bac je
l'aimais dit bon sang c'est bien ce
qu'ils ont à nous ceux ci pouvaient pas
ignorer ce gros ça veut dire qu'il va
passer avec une merde désolé pour ceux
qui sont rattrapage au top 50 pour les
gars il va en avoir besoin d'un coup on
va faire comment nous pour la bannière
je vous promets que je vais devenir un
groupe d'amis à 18 ans je devrais tout
soit en quoi ça nous avons des halles on
y va premier arrivé au metalist
si vous les arts dans l'est a longtemps
yumi va troquer les doigts du cul n y va
pas rester tout le week-end datacore ok
tu sors l'enfant qui déjà
[Applaudissements]
on y croit l'égalera mon mémoire
au gabon on a tenté tout ce que tu sais
que l'été fatwa
socrates ne dis pas que là ça fou ce que
je sais c'est que je ne fasse pas dans
votre cas j'avais cru comprendre après
que samuel mois nous avons tant prié
pour ça
le contact a comme ses émissions de
prendre possession des poupées graphique
nous sommes rendu compte que ce n'était
pas tant de français qui bénéficie du
besoin d'être jamais détruit
il souvent que qu'elle même si on peut
pas voir dieu on peut on te sentir sa
présence dans cette maison j'adore les
nôtres au top de présence une présence
disposition
les trois mois que je suis d'appeler
serait si tu me dis que ça va tout va
bien c'est qu'annie elle a trouvé une
poupée à l'eau alors qu'elle pourrait
sceller déclare ou blanches qui jadis tu
dois pas s'approcher d'elle
[Applaudissements]
bennis et moi ma soeur parce que j'étais
les poupées capitainerie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
à tanger une proposition malhonnête
évidemment à te faire j'ai sex and the
singing pourrez le regarder ensemble
gentiment champigny sequans il ya des
femmes le plus connu c'est la fub cette
fille regarde elle était la fille d un
vert très bien
affi
j'essaie rire toi pour être un maniaque
donc voilà ciao ferring la partir de
quand on peut considérer qu'on connaît
vraiment plus tard la première monte en
classe à part justin c'est bon j'ai tort
de ne pas avoir assez
[Musique]
les commentaires du genre de questions
ce contexte ses prédécesseurs les hommes
une droite je te dis jamais me dire non
je crois qu'à ce compte plusieurs vues
des clients c'est vrai qu'un client ni
[Musique]
abattu et comme je t'aime mais il ya des
choses que je peux pas te dit tu dois me
faire confiance
brass band tu m'as volé quelque chose
bon le mois où ton fils ne rentrera pas
à la maison
je croyais que m à koufa qu'il n'y a pas
si longtemps ma kidman mars en autriche
comble cette ville et des affaires
internes méchante policière c'est moussa
[Musique]
koné l'armée près arroser tous les flics
sans exception pour voir vincent d'armor
ça
il touche à mon fils stocker
[Musique]
à l'ennemi d'allah et qu'est ce que tu
préfères paiera d'audard pour ta terre
mourir face à l'urgence de la situation
nous annonçons solennellement la coudée
dans notre organisation
[Musique]
je gagne bonne famille et on était
gamins du bourgeois
chez nous on attend aujourd'hui que tu
peux faire de mieux dans ta vie de
battre quand on dit pourtant peuple
[Applaudissements]
sommes une armée légitime l'armée du
peuple
nous n'avons de comptes à rendre qu'à
lui à lui seul ce stade mais la salle
est là pourquoi il est chez lui je ne
sais pas d'où tu te prends des cordes
bord de ba et ba na tu veux pas prendre
des bagarres tous les noirs tu vas pays
nous avons ouvert un front contre toutes
les autres structures dans l'île contre
les pats maintenant le milieu mais il va
jamais tenir que bien attention à qui tu
donnes ta confiance
essayer de faire passer un message
dites-leur on s'éloigne méthodiquement
et sûrement de la maisonnée l'homme
habitait chapelet 10 6 snow zones de
combat
en suisse il représente plus rien
retombées de cette règle c'est la règle
[Musique]
ça
s'il s'est plutôt être juste
complètement la tumeur d'amoureux de la
battait quoi c'est un mélange de
plaquettes de surtitrage s'appelle
comment déjà
comme fabrice 7/4 jeudi
[Musique]
je t'embrasse cambronne tupper la pièce
le kangourou personnes
m
c'est contre la fumée passive la
république avait pas d'alternative
après c'est un vilain tour au tour de
turquie dans ce qu'on fait à bagnères
joséphine bacon pantalon du boubou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà comment est ce que vous ne
captez fallait pas continuer à chanter à
faire de la musique
rendez vous
car la vitesse si j'étais perdu je sais
pas pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à